Brown bear, brown bear, what do you see?
I see a red bird looking at me.
Red bird, red bird, what do you see?
I see a yellow duck looking at me.
Yellow duck, yellow duck, what do you see?
I see a blue horse looking at me.
Blue horse, blue horse, what do you see?
I see a green frog looking at me.
Green frog, green frog, what do you see?
I see a purple cat looking at me.
Purple cat, purple cat, what do you see?
I see a white dog looking at me.
White dog, white dog, what do you see?
I see a black sheep looking at me.
Black sheep, black sheep, what do you see?
I see a goldfish looking at me.
Goldfish, goldfish, what do you see?
I see a teacher looking at me.
Teacher, teacher, what do you see?
I see children looking at me.
Children, children, what do you see?
We see a brown bear, a red bird, a yellow duck, a blue horse,...
...a green frog, a purple cat, a white dog, a black sheep,...
...a goldfish, and a teacher looking at us.
That's what we see.